[Music]
christopher mintz ploss first gained
fame by cracking audiences
up as mclovin in 2007 superbad he
continued working steadily since then
but a lot of fans haven't seen him on
screen very much lately
keep watching to discover why that is
ever since he obtained the world's
fakest
fake id and charmed a couple of board
police officers in superbad
mints plos has forever been known as
mclovin
even though he's gone on to star in
other notable movies like role models
kick-ass and neighbors his first role is
still undoubtedly his most well-known
that's a fine state of affairs for
actors who are satisfied with being cult
figures forever but
it's not so great if you want to have a
robust and steady mainstream career
unfortunately for mints plos then it's
hard for audiences
and studio executives to see him as
anything other than mclovin
it's no exaggeration to say that
superbad has overshadowed
every single thing mints plos has done
since it's a fair bet that at least half
his fans
don't even recognize him by his real
name and
while the cachet of that performance
continues to draw crowds for his other
projects
it isn't helping him branch out or move
forward into more serious roles
i am mclovin between maturing into
adulthood
and losing his baby chipmunk cheeks
minceplas has followed in the footsteps
of so many teen movie nerd actors before
him by becoming a conventionally
attractive man
and yet nobody seems to realize it
including hollywood and perhaps even
mince ploss himself
so for whoever needs to hear it here's
the truth christopher mintz ploss
is a handsome man with his comedy skills
and very pleasant face
he could easily hold his own as an every
man romantic lead or he could just as
easily play the part of the likable best
friend
but instead his potential as a perfectly
respectable leading man is hidden under
a steady stream of type casting and
voice over rolls
all he needs is a big juicy part that
declares his newfound image to the world
but it just hasn't arrived yet to sum it
up mince plus
is probably dealing with the
double-edged sword that belongs to
former child stars who played one major
role
early in their careers it's as if he
needs to look like his 17 year old self
in order to be recognizable and land
roles but he's aged out of those roles
that his original reputation would help
him land
in may 2012 mince plos scored
potentially his biggest
post super bad role yet when cbs
announced that it had ordered a sitcom
called
friend me he was set to star in it
alongside nicholas braun as
two guys who leave their indiana
hometown in favor of los
angeles and jobs at groupon minsploss
played the nerdy one who's content to
hang out at home talking to his old
friends online
the show seemed poised to be the perfect
transitional vehicle for him as
a major network series could have been a
springboard to all kinds of big deal
roles
but tragically friendme creator alan
kirschenbaum killed himself before the
show premiered
cbs decided to leave the show out of its
lineup and never aired a single one of
the eight episodes that had already
been produced obviously a blow to one's
career plans
pales in comparison to death but this
was nevertheless a tough break for mince
plos
mints plos's super bad cast mates have
largely gone on to have high profile
careers
michael sarah has starred in cult hits
like scott pilgrim vs the world and juno
while jonah hill has transitioned
between traditional comedies and
awards baiting films like the wolf of
wall street
some of them have even won oscars as
emma stone took home the gold for la la
land
in comparison mince ploss's public
profile is nowhere near as high
being in big movies means playing the
hollywood glad-handing game but
mince ploss just doesn't seem to be too
interested in all that
sure he'll occasionally pose with
friends and co-stars on the red carpet
before a movie premiere but other than
that
his media presence is notably low-key
his instagram followers are far more
likely to see him cuddling with dogs or
goofing off in his kitchen than hanging
out at an exclusive
nightclub his personal life is just that
personal
he also doesn't get much attention for
his love life thus avoiding any
tumultuous tabloid ready affairs
in short he's just not chasing the kind
of fame that might make him more of a
household name
after the cancellation of friend me
mints plos got another chance to star on
another cbs sitcom about people in their
20s working for an internet company
entitled the great indoors it also
starred joel mchale and stephen fry
as the editor and publisher of an
outdoors magazine while mince ploss
played a nerdy computer whiz the show
finished the 2016-2017 season
as the 38th most watched show on network
tv
that may not sound too shabby but it was
apparently disappointing to cbs as it
was cancelled
after just one season it certainly
didn't help that critics
also hated the series with the hollywood
reporter for one calling it quote
a malaise of millennial minstrels being
associated with a failed sitcom
given every chance to succeed can't be a
good look for anyone's career
uh oh let me help you with this pack
here
around the same time that the great
indoors was underwhelming viewers mints
plus
appeared in another quickly forgotten tv
series
flaked was a netflix dramedy that
premiered in 2017 about addiction
recovery that starred will arnett
once again mince plus played a socially
awkward techie the show lasted a mere
two seasons with mince plos showing up
in three episodes of the first season
mince ploss
isn't just an actor he's also a
dedicated musician
and his projects on that front are
clearly just as important to him as
being on screen
he's spending a lot of his time these
days practicing performing and recording
with his indie rock band main man
while he's definitely the most famous
member of that group outside of music he
doesn't have the showiest role in the
band as he strums away on the bass
guitar
still he knows where to find his
audience as the band debuted their very
70s style video for its steely dan
esque single wwh on funnier dye's
youtube channel in 2017
and main man isn't even mince ploss's
only musical project
as he drummed for a group called the
young rapscallions and played bass for
another band called bear on fire
splitting his time this way
is exactly what he wants to keep doing
in 2015 he told stereogum
i would love to keep balancing the two i
think i'm very lucky and grateful for
where i am right now that i can do both
acting you can work for three months and
not work for six months
so in that time i love the momentum of
music and everything that's going on
the momentum right now is very musical i
kind of just go with the flow
while mince plus isn't headlining big
studio comedies these days he does
frequently show up for a supporting role
or cameo appearance in movies involving
his super bad cast mate seth rogen these
gigs keep minceplos
in the public eye and allow him to stay
busy making the kind of movies that made
him famous in the first place
they also keep him around as a solid
part of rogan's prolific and lucrative
filmmaking enterprise
for example in 2017's the disaster
artist which rogan co-produced and had a
supporting role in mins plos has a small
uncredited role
he had a bigger part in 2013's
apocalyptic comedy this is the end in
which
rogan and his usual gang of
collaborators play heightened
terrible versions of themselves who lose
their minds as the world
ends mince plos shows up as himself to
be sucked into hell
rogan even let mince plos deliver a
completely absurd male anatomy joke in
2014's neighbors in which he played
scoony a ridiculously well-endowed young
man
it seems that as long as minsplas's
colleagues are still making movies
they'll often have a part with his name
on it
you may not have seen mince plos too
much lately but there's a good chance
you've heard him
he's been a go-to player for dreamworks
animation for a while now
ever since he landed the role of
thoughtful viking fishlegs in 2010's how
to train your dragon
he's gone on to reprise that role in
multiple sequels and tv shows and he
worked with dreamworks again on the
trolls franchise as the voice of the
villainous king gristle
mintz place no longer sports the whiny
voice he utilized with great skill as
mclovin
he's in fact developed into a skilled
and versatile voiceover performer
playing characters in the likes of such
projects as marmaduke and paranorman
becoming an in-demand voice actor isn't
a bad thing by any stretch
it's great work for an actor with a
particular skill set and mince ploss's
enthusiastic vocal performances
indicate that he loves doing it entire
careers can unfold within the realm of
voice acting that are just as lucrative
creatively challenging and memorable as
ones rooted in live action
but even with all these positive
attributes voice acting is simply not
going to get mince ploss's face on the
radar of hollywood casting agents the
same way that live
action parts would five years after
superbad exploded onto the big screen
mince plos was given an opportunity to
break out of his mclovin image while
still remaining within the fold of big
hollywood comedies
in 2012 he joined the cast of get a job
which was helmed by roger dodger
director dylan kidd
mince ploss was cast as ethan a
housemate of the main character will
played by miles teller
will is a recent college graduate who
doesn't quite know what to do with
himself professionally upon being thrust
into
adulthood ethan winds up being the most
financially if dubiously successful
member of will's social group when he
designs a popular smartphone app that
enables stalkers
say there's a person that you want to
find but they don't want to be found
right okay like there's this girl
and you've called her a million times
since she just won't return your
messages
unfortunately get a job didn't do much
to advance mensplace's momentum
at a critically important stage in his
career distribution issues initially
delayed its release by two years
and ultimately it wouldn't be available
to the public until
2016. that's a whopping four years after
it was filmed in 2012
a whole bachelor's degree's worth of
time to add insult to injury
critics seriously hated the movie with
dan mecca of the film stage calling it
quote
a brutally cynical largely unfunny film
it was released straight to home video
in the united states though it did play
to theater goers in south africa where
it earned a little more than 23 thousand
dollars
mince plos certainly got a job making
this movie but it didn't really lead to
any further ones
one reason for mince ploss's low
visibility in hollywood is that he seems
to genuinely prefer
things this way between his private
nature his choice to pursue supporting
roles
his frequent voice acting gigs and his
musical pursuits there's little sign
that he even wants to headline
blockbusters or take the lead in a major
network sitcom but if he ever does want
to pursue
either of those things it's definitely
not too late for him to do so he's got
the acting chops to make it happen
not to mention the goodwill that comes
from co-starring in superbad
an enduringly popular millennial
touchstone a career is never really dead
in hollywood it just needs the right
jump start
and in recent years mince ploss has
finally started shedding the nerd roles
so commonly offered to him
in fact his career has taken recent
turns into more artistic
and idiosyncratic territory in 2019 he
was hired to play a small but pivotal
role as a creepy guy in 2020's
satirical thriller promising young woman
which starred carrie mulligan as a woman
seeking to avenge her best friend by
preying on men who claimed to be nice
guys
i just thought that you were drunk yeah
really drunk
yeah well i'm not but that's good isn't
it
i think you should leave and mince plos
has also been getting weird by voicing
sun in the grotesquely puppeteered
comedy central series blarkinson
so in reality mince plos is still
hanging with comedy's cool kids just in
a slightly different way than he used to
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one